The moment you've all been waiting for!
A female poet...
Emily Dickinson.
A woman should receive an education,
but it should not be the same as a man's.
Maybe they're scared that
if they teach us how the world works,
we'll figure out how to take over.
Morning, ladies.
I don't know how the two of you
fit into such a tiny bed.
I have one purpose.
To become a great writer.
And there's nothing you can do to stop me.
-She's so insane.
-Of course she's insane.
She's Emily Dickinson.
You need to cut out these sort of antics.
I have to do something, Sue.
Desperate times, girl.
Don't act like you're dead
while you're still alive.
If you want something,
reach out and grab it!
Sick.
You'll be the only Dickinson
they talk about in 200 years.
I promise you that.
That was a lovely funeral,
don't you think?
Mine'll be better.